Vodan puje mi.
Daman puje mi.
Sangam puje mi.
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambhu dasa
Iti piso bhagava arahamsambhasambhodo vijacaranasampanno sugato lokavidu anuttaro purisadam sarati sata deva manusanam bodho bhagavati
Je čá Buda a títá čá, je čá Buda a nága tá, pachupáná čá je Buda a hangvandámi sápadá, náty mé sáranán ganyán, buddho mé sáranán gwarán, eténa sácha vajé ná, hotu mé čá já mangalán,
kájéna váčá čiténa, pámádéna majákatán, hačéán kámámé bánté, bůrý páňá tatágatán.
Svákáto bhagavatá dámo, sánditíko akáliko, hejí pásíko opanájíko, pachátán veditá bovinjuhíti.
Ye ca dhamma ati taca, ye ca dhamma anagata, pachupang na ca ye dhamma aham vandami sabbata.
Nati me saranam ganyam, tambo me saranam varam, etena sacca vajena, hotu me jaya mangalam.
kajena vachachitena pamadena mayakatam achyam khammedhamma sandhitika akalika supatipanno bhagavato savakasangho ujupatipanno bhagavato savakasangho
Nyāyāpatipanno bhagavato sāvakasangho, samicchipatipanno bhagavato sāvakasangho.
Yadidhāñcatāri puri sāyugāni atta puri sāpukalā, hesa bhagavato sāvakasangho.
Ahunejo, pahunejo, dakinejo, anjalikaraniyo, anuttarang, punyakedang, lokasati.
Jejasanga, atitacha, jejasanga, anagadam, pachupanacha, yesanga, ahanguandam, isapadam.
Nati me saranam ganyam, sangome saranam varam, etena sacca vajena, hutume jaya mangalam, kajena vachacitena, pamadena mayakatam, acciam kamame sanga, punyaketam ganuttaram.
Aneka jati sansarang, sanda vysangang ibisang, gahakaraka gawe santo, duka jati punapunang, gahakaraka detozi, punagehang nakahazi, sabate pasukabhaga, gahakutang visangatang.
Vysankaragatanchitam tananam kaya macchagam.
Avijapachya sankara sankara pachya vijnanam.
Vijnanam pachya namarupam namarupapachya salayatanam.
Salayatanapachya pasopasapachya vedanam.
vedana pachyá tanhá tanhá pachyá upádaná upádaná pachyá bhavá bhavá pachyá jati jati pachyá jará bhádaná soká paridevá duká domanás upáyásá sambhá vanti he vangetásá kevalásá duká kandásá samudá johoti
A vijajá tvevá asézá, viragá nirodá, sankhára nirodá.
Sankhára nirodá, vijnána nirodá.
Vijnána nirodá, námá rupá nirodá.
Námá rupá nirodá, sála jatná nirodá.
salajatana nirodha pasa nirodho pasa nirodha vedana nirodho vedana nirodha tanna nirodho tanna nirodha upadana nirodho upadana nirodho bhava nirodho bhava nirodho jati nirodho
Jati nirodha, jara, marana, sukha, parideva, dukkha, domna, supaya, sani, rujanti, hevange, tasa, kevalasa, dukkha, kandasa, nirodho, hoti.
Sabe sankhara nityati, yad apanyaya pasati, atane bindati duke, esamago vissudhyam.
Sabe sankhara dukati, yad apanyaya pasati, atane bindati duke, esamago vissudhyam.
Sabe dama anatati, yad apanya yapasati, atani bindati duke, esamago visudhya.
Anicca vata sankhara, upadavaya damino, upajitva nirujanti, tezang upasamosuko.
Dukhavata sankhara upadvajadamino upajitva nirujanti tezang upasamosukho.
Anatavata sankhara upadvajadamino upajitva nirujanti tezang upasamosukho.
Imájá dámánu dámá pati pati já bodhám pujéni.
Imájá dámánu dámá pati pati já dámám pujéni.
Imájá dámánu dámá páté páté já sáňkám půjémí.